yuri on ice
were you just trying to get trying to
like piss off twitter that day
no i just genuinely thought it was
[ __ ] boring
i just thought it was [ __ ] boring i'm
sorry look oh come
on i don't want to get into this again
man like at the time i got so much [ __ ]
for it
i remember did you did you make an
apology video
yeah no because people because i said
that i didn't like
you know you made because at the time
at the time like uranus was like the
hardest thing right back like i don't
know i don't remember when it was like
2016 2017 something like that
and uh and all i said in the video was i
don't think euronice was uh oh no i said
something along the lines of uh
99 of people watching your own ice for
the yowie elements one percent watch it
for the actual sport element
and so many euro nice stands called me
homosexual because
oh sorry not homosexual life
uh homophobic yeah they call me
homophobic because of it
uh first of all hey i'm not homophobic
he also gave three of five joey so yeah
because because free i gave a higher
score than uranus
because again because kyoto animation
animated that way better than they did
here on ice
i i don't really think there's any world
like any review that you could warrant
that
you're not just below a five like it was
a really good story
like it was it was minimum five i think
what would you give it what would you
give it
[Music]
i would give it a six i think
but like you could you reasonably put it
below a five like at a four
i mean if it's not your thing because
the the thing about stories
the thing the thing about yuri and ice
is that they introduce way too many
characters
and they just like kind of didn't focus
on any of them also i'm sorry i couldn't
stand the main [ __ ] character
i love the guy who just came while he's
dancing that guy was funny as [ __ ] oh
yeah that was yeah again there was some
funny parts
there's a reason why i didn't give it a
one right like there were some parts
about it
wow wow there's a reason i didn't give
it a 1. that's the reason i didn't give
it a 1.
there were some parts about it but like
was it a [ __ ] like slog
to watch all of it yeah no it was good i
was like
every episode passed i was like i could
be watching something else surprise
accusing beat you up for saying
something like that yeah
i thought you really liked it yeah she
likes it and she's like well that's your
opinion